here we aren't the wired party taking a
break from the show floor at CES 2012
man CES is like bringing an entire city
into the Las Vegas Convention Center
something like 140,000 people are
attending this year and each company
that's showcasing their products has to
build these elaborate boots to show off
their products some of these places
build multi-story structures there's
walls of 3d TVs there's rooms for
demoing products it's crazy I love
getting to play with the new products
that are coming out like the HTC Titan
to and the Nokia Lumia 900 and I also
enjoy getting to meet all my colleagues
um all the other journalists all around
the world that maybe I talked with on
Twitter all the time and now I get to
meet them in person but now i think i'm
going to go dance